russian president vladimir putin and his
ally the president of belarus are being
blamed for stoking new tensions in
eastern europe today poland used water
cannons to push back migrants along the
border with belarus which is accused of
encouraging thousands of middle eastern
refugees to cross the frontier belarus
is facing new sanctions from the
european union charlie daggett is near
the polish belarus border with more on
the story
by the thousands they mass stranded and
freezing in an increasingly tense
standoff at the border between belarus
and poland
poland refuses to let anyone in blaming
belarus of weaponizing migrants to
destabilize the european union
a few make a break into the woods under
the cover of night risking arrest or
worse these two brothers from syria were
rushed to the hospital suffering from
suspected hypothermia
this is the desperate situation the
migrants have been forced into they were
lucky enough to cross the border into
poland but it is bitterly cold we saw an
ambulance take them away if they had not
been found they may not have survived
aid worker agata koloji said they were
barely conscious
this is something that we're seeing
every day and it's gonna get worse
because it's getting colder at night
the u.s and europe accused belarus
president alexander lukashenko of
manufacturing a migrant crisis by
granting tourist visas even organizing
flights to migrants from the middle east
on the promise of an easy entry into the
eu
retaliation for eu sanctions imposed
after last year's disputed election in
belarus
from northern iraq told us they were
beaten by belarusian soldiers
it was very hard no water no food he
said we were arrested by polish police
and brought to this isolation camp
the dispute has escalated with
accusations of russian interference
poland deploying 15 000 troops to the
border while russia sends bombers to
patrol belarusian airspace as its
paratroopers conduct joint exercises
along the border
meanwhile the migrants remain trapped
unwilling pawns on the front line of a
geopolitical battle with tensions rising
and temperatures dropping by the day
now this checkpoint is as close as we
can get to the border the polish
government have set up a two and a half
mile exclusion zone meanwhile at the
border there are reports that migrants
tried to charge the fence one migrant
told us polish police fired on them
using rubber bullets and tear gas
nate
charlie dagetta as usual informative and
powerful important thank you so much